نبدا متطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث قال
مستشار زعيم الانفصاليين
فيسكي قال ان قوه فاغن الروسيه تتقدم داخل
مدينه باخمه مشيرا الى ان القوات الروسيه
تسيطر على جميع الطرق المؤديه الى المدينه
واكد كيما كوفيدكي ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تحاول تسليما معدات الى مقاتلها
خسائر فادحه مشيرا الى ان جميع الطرق تحت
السيطره الا انه اعتبر انه لا يزال من
السابق لاوانه الحديث عن تطويق المدينه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مستعره ليس في مدينه باقمت وحدها وانما في
مدن عديده اهمها بالامس على سبيل المثال
كانت المعارك اكثر عنفا في مدينه افديفيكا
ومحاوله كبيره لاقتحام المدينه من قبل
القوات الروسيه الفرقه الخامسه عشر كانت
بالفعل يعني تجري عمليات عسكريه كبيره حول
المدينه بعد تطويقها من جانبين التطويق
هناك يعني
يشمل
النواحي
الجنوبيه الغربيه
الجنوبيه عفوا الجنوبيه الغربيه
والشماليه الشرقيه يحاول الجيش الروسي
تطويق المدينه ويحاول اقتحامها لكنه لم
يفلح حتى الان لكن هناك اسلحه متطوره
تستخدم الحديث عن اكثر من 35 الف قذيفه
وصاروخ تطلق في المنطقه هنا مقاطعه دانياس
في كل المدن التي تجري فيها المعارك على
سبيل المثال مدينه مارينكا دخلت القوات
ايضا الروسيه الى المناطق الاقصى الاكثر
قربا من نهايه الحدود الاداريه للمدينه هو
الثلث الاخير من المدينه الذي لم يسيطر
عليه الجيش الروسي حتى الان تبقى مدينه
باخمت هي الاكثر سخونه تبقى مدينه باخموت
المعضله الكبرى حيث تحاول قوات فاجنر
اختراق المدينه من عده نواحي ودخلتها
بالفعل الحديث بالامس عن كيلو مترين اقل
من قيل مترين تفصل القوات الروسيه عن مركز
مدينه باخمت القوات الروسيه دخلت من
المحور الجنوبي ووصلت الى المجمعات
السكنيه وسيطرت على عده يعني مبادئ سكنيه
واسالك عن ان الخسائر الروسيه في ضخمه
كبيره جدا بحسب التقرير الوارده لكن هذا
يدفع للتساؤل حول
هذه المدينه بنسبه للروس ام انها فقط هي
مجرد معبر مهم نحو مدن اكثر اكثر اهميه
هناك قواعد عسكريه كبيره للجيش الاوكراني
من الطبيعي ان حسم مدينه باغموت لن يكون
قريبا او بالسهوله يعني لن يكون اليوم او
غدا لان دائما ما يسيطر الجيش الروسي على
ثلثي اي مدينه او اي نقطه يعني مركزيه
للقوات الاوكرانيه ويبقى الجزء الاخير وهو
الغربي لان القوات الاوكرانيه تكمن دائما
في المناطق الغربيه